we've been talking about the Dakota
access pipeline where protesters have
been clashing not only with police but
with other law enforcement agencies as
well over the construction of this 1170
mile pipeline in North Dakota about 40
miles south of Bismarck is where the
majority of the protesters have been and
this involves the Standing Rock Sioux
and other Native American tribes the the
concerns are concerns that make a lot of
sense to me right fears that the
pollution of the Missouri River from
this pipeline would be a significant and
negative thing that sacred cultural
lands think about that we've given
Native American tribes these very
specifically carved out areas and then
all of a sudden fossil fuels wants to
come in and go through some of those
small areas that we've designated from
people whose country we took away from
them and I know country is not the exact
right word we're talking about land not
necessarily an organized country or
nation-state as we talk about it today
but I think you get the idea the big
news is that there are now two thousand
veterans planning to gather next week at
the reservation to serve as human
shields for protesters now why would the
protesters need human shields well
because of everything we've seen
happening to them water cannons with
cold water in sub-zero temperatures
rubber bullets hundreds of people being
taken to local hospitals assault and
intimidation at the hands of
increasingly militarized police forces
Michael Wood jr. is the founder of the
veterans group the veterans event rather
that is going to be doing this
he's a former guest on the show former
Baltimore police officer really
interesting interview with him that you
can check out and Wood said he was
hoping to attract 5,000 veterans and he
had to cut it off
when they reached 2,000 veterans because
it was just getting too big to even
manage in a sort of practical way over
half a million dollars in pledges as of
yesterday to pay for food and
transportation and supplies etc and
authorities meanwhile guys are saying we
may start finding people to block
supplies from getting in
we heard from the governor jack
Dalrymple that there's a mandatory
evacuation order saying it's because of
anticipated harsh weather conditions but
of course many people very suspicious of
that because they've been trying to
figure out a way to get these protesters
out for a very very long time so this is
continuing to escalate and I know that
some of us thought not necessarily you
guys but there were thoughts among that
some in our audience who emailed me
saying this is going to end soon and and
we're just never going to hear about it
again it doesn't appear that it's going
to end soon now or we could just see the
next stage of it it's like that old
saying where if you call the police then
I'll call the army right yeah it's great
to see veterans long after they've been
discharged continued to serve the public
because it seems like the police aren't
protecting and serving us in this case
throughout this whole debacle it kind of
seemed that the police the militarized
and the the brute force shown by the
police kind of was disproportionate to
the threat posed by the activists I'll
say yeah I don't think your assessment
that there is wrong anybody looking at
this and and we heard many lies also
from representatives for though there
was a sheriff's department or a police
department remember exactly and they
were critiqued for using these water
cannons just on protesters and freezing
cold temperatures and they said oh no
there weren't standalone water cannons
this was just hoses hooked up to fire
trucks and they were being used to put
out fires now protesters have had drones
and we played the drone footage for you
last week where you could see these were
not number one there were no fires that
were being put out by some of these
water cannons and number two they were
water cannons it was not hoses that were
hooked up to fire trucks I mean just
flat-out caught lying and they were
quite reminiscent to of the 1960s
demonstrations where protesters had
water cannons Yeah right on them and
that rallied a lot of public support
behind that cause this has been the
worst of militarization of police it's
going to continue there are lawsuits for
excessive use of force and the most
troubling thing about this what's
happening to the protesters is horrible
but the most troubling thing is this is
all over fossil fuels that we don't need
if we truly committed and obviously if
we had committed 15 years ago this would
be a non-issue but even more scary is
the connection
between this and the Trump presidency
right Trump is a shareholder in one of
the companies that stands to make money
from this pipeline Trump plans to do
massive deregulation for fossil fuel
harvesting which will make pipelines
like this even more common that to me is
you know I have personal concern for the
protesters that are being impacted by
this but the bigger picture is that
under a president Donald administration
these types of pipelines which we should
be getting away from completely are
going to be more common and I don't know
that that narrative is being discussed
enough Rachel I think that should be a
more prevalent narrative I think it is
being discussed though because people
are talking about it in the larger
context of his business holdings and
partnerships okay
yeah which do stand to get very sticky
as we move forward yeah and we're gonna
be discussing that much more tomorrow
supposed big announcements coming about
Donald Trump's uh business holdings but
it what saddest for me Pat is that
there's a conversation here that we've
been pushing for for a long time which
is hey you know what we have options for
energy where this doesn't even come up
rubber bullets don't come out if you
start moving towards alternative energy
water cannons in sub-zero temperatures
on protesters don't come out when you
get away from fracking and pipelines and
oil and and natural gas and coal etc and
it's I guess it's sort of there as
rachel is saying in in one context but
the bigger picture is we've we've really
dropped the ball on moving away from
this type of energy
yeah and it's a sad case for your cause
that that's the sort of tactics you have
to use to enforce oil and and put that
on to people instead of greener newer
technology no doubt about it so there's
probably like four or five layers here
one is militarization of police another
is the sort of total lack of respect for
supposedly sacred Native American lands
that were mostly hand-picked by by the
American government number three is the
the broader energy implications for is
the Donald Trump business interests and
there's probably five or six there as
well let's take a break send me your
thoughts about this on Twitter I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman and the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show
and we'll be back with more after this
today's program is made possible in part
by movement watches at M VMT watches
komm I'm wearing my movement watch today
which I love I went with the white face
and the tan band which is a look I
really like and all the other watches I
have are darker and so I thought this
would be a good fit but they have so
many different washes that are really
great gifts and now that we're getting
into the holiday buying season for me
doing the entire chaos at the mall to
get a five hundred dollar watch at the
department store move that's not my move
at all
but the get a $95 watch watch is
starting at $95 at MV mt watches dot-com
/ Pakman for some of the people in my
life that I'm going to be getting gifts
for that is more my move and you can get
15% off as well as free shipping as well
as free returns if you go to mV mt
watches dot-com / Pakman that is PA que
ma n